this game that I'm about to play right
here is called guess the dinosaur
everybody know this what's his mouth
yeah a nice little triceratops
Triceratops laying before Tom this was
Sarah too you watched land before Tom
the cartoon of course the second
dinosaur we got here you had this on
your birthday cake you gotta know this
one right here when I get a sack at home
actually this is the animal that pops up
on the Jumbotron Spinosaurus is my
favorite and I can't miss it that's dope
man it's dope third dinosaur that we got
you know it doesn't have the frill like
it did in Jurassic Park but that's still
a Dilophosaurus this is the one where he
was in there he's tried to pet it and it
just it like spit in his eye yeah it
made like a little sound
they made the little sound out of them
fourth dinosaur that we got right here
um it's the largest land carnivore to
have ever lived well I can't say that
with confirmation because I know
Spinosaurus existed and it was longer
and I know T-Rex was believed to be
heavier but not quite as long but in
between
Giganotosaurus gigantosaurus
Giganotosaurus